did you see
the latest [ __ ] with kevin durant and
michael rappaport
how it blew up like the dms yeah he
exposed his dms
and he was talking michael ravenport's
like go help the kids in brownsville you
piece of [ __ ]
and uh and then
all the talks the sports talk shows like
undisputed and all them they're all
talking about i even had michael
rappaport on there
and michael rappaport even kind of
called himself out he was just like look
he's like yeah i've been in hollywood my
whole life
i've never he he's the king of [ __ ] talk
but he can't handle the [ __ ] talk
but yeah robert's a funny guy i've been
on i've been on his podcast we had a
we had a really good time have you
really yeah yeah
that's hilarious man he's a funny
[ __ ] he's hilarious
and and a nice guy a smart doesn't
surprise me that he wound up calling
himself out
because like you know you have to have a
little self-awareness you know
in this game and can we all agree that
sometimes social media gets out of hand
i mean we all agree that sometimes
you know we we don't converse first of
all it's no place for nuance
number one in 280 characters or whatever
even a thread
it's no place for nuance and [ __ ]
escalates quick
and everybody it becomes a game of
one-upsmanship rather than
an opportunity to find common ground and
actually
uh you know have a productive uh you
know discourse or debate
uh on on something you know i think
that's the i think that's
problematic you know and but good for
good for rappaport for just saying like
you know for for having some fun with it
because like
you know i there's a lot of times where
i like you know you go for the easy yo
mama joke because you're sitting on the
couch and like who's this [ __ ]
tweeting at me
about you know stupid [ __ ] you know with
the with the with the name and these
you know [ __ ] number salad afterwards
you know like who you know who is this
you know but like sometimes i wish that
you know i would
bite my fingers or be a little bit more
uh productive but and constructed but
sometimes you can't sometimes people are
just
dicks you know yeah well rappaport i
mean he roasts
everybody on his social media he posts
[ __ ] every single day on his twitter and
his instagram roasting the [ __ ] out of
people
it's hilarious you know that's hilarious
he's great at it he's great
that's a tremendous [ __ ] talent he
has actually i have a theory
it's kind of a funny way brings it back
to uh to savage but like
um so i have a theory that what we've
seen over like the last 20 years with
the hyper
extreme partisanship basically
everything in america
whether it's politics whether it's major
league baseball whether it's
uh i mean you name it podcast twitter
everything has become
the wwe it's
all like sports entertainment political
entertainment
social justice entertainment whatever it
is
it's like and some people i think are
playing characters or
or are are um you know they have
personas
that they're kind of putting out there
with i'm kind of one person i don't have
a lot of
like sometimes i'm a little more
aggressive on social media but otherwise
it's just an extension of myself but i
think some people are very
are very different people than they are
on say
twitter fox news a podcast whatever they
are in real life
and that's the the wwe what is it about
you go on
you go on fox news you're cutting a
promo right like those democrats
you're looking for uh story lines
and narratives you're looking uh and
what's better than the uh what's better
than a heel turn
what's better than you know when a babe
when a face speak you know when a good
guy becomes a villain or
or vice versa those are some of the
biggest so some of those are some of the
best
uh story lines in in professional
wrestling so i think a lot of this has
become that storyline
you know beef generated uh hip-hop
i think probably could get some credit
for the beef is good for business
uh uh world uh when it doesn't you know
turn into something more violent but
like to me it's
it's all wwe we made screwball which is
about
alex rodriguez and the biogenesis
steroid scandal in miami
i learned that quick because everybody's
like because it ends of course like
a-rod is like
ostracized right he goes from like one
of the highest paid the highest paid
baseball player in history
to like this cheater this liar he's you
know he gets this
the biggest suspension of all time loses
tens of millions of dollars in the
process
and then retires and he's like
kind of back in a ceremonial position on
the yankees mentoring young players
he's back on broadcasts you know do it
and like and there he is posing
with manfred the you know the
commissioner of mlb
who like tried to ostracize i mean they
went at it
like this you know this this david
goliath or almost goliath versus goliath
kind of battle of the legacies with bud
sealing the former commissioner
uh rob manfred who actually was ceilings
right-hand man
who oversaw the entire investigation
against a-rod it was a pretty shady
investigation
uh by the way um you know well that's
the thing you come down to florida you
come down to the swamp you're gonna get
a little mud on you you know like that's
just
you roll around you roll around with us
uh uh you know
uh swamp creatures down here you're
gonna get some mud but you know
um what was interesting is that you know
we end with like again their arms around
each other like all is well
and everybody said like how did that
happen like how did you know
and i said listen i said it's twofold
first of all it's the new american
values
um the new american we used to teach our
kids um honesty integrity
the golden rule do unto others right as
you'd have done unto you
somehow it became the message we sent
our kids was
it's every man woman and child for
themselves lie
cheat and steal or do whatever you have
to do to get ahead
and that's like and that seems to be the
message you know
live cheat and steal and you could be
the the you know uh the highest paid
baseball player of all time live cheat
and steal and you could be the
the commissioner of major league
baseball live cheat and steal and you
two kids can be president of the united
states i don't think that's a good
message for generations of youth that
are growing up
and will grow up now um but more
importantly what
a-rod did was the heel turn the face
turn
he he was the heel and now he was the
hero he was the babyface you know
and and so uh uh you know rob manfred is
the new commissioner baseball at that
time
the vince mcmahon of the operation he
know he's no dummy
he knows you know which side his bread's
buttered on he says hey
let's bring a rod into the fold it'll be
if nothing else it'll be good television
right it'll be a good story line
the blogosphere will explode ratings
will go up and that's
ultimately that's the goal right is more
more money more eyeballs more money more
clicks to your point you know and so
i think that's what's happened
everything has become
the wwe instead of you know instead of
politics instead of
social media instead of even maybe
journalism it's now
entertainment right sports entertainment
now entertainment is the second word you
almost have to put after
everything so what's what's rappaport
doing to his credit he's a comedian
for crying an actor like he's not a you
know
he's not a political commentator he's
not running for office
or seeking the public trust he's an
entertainer and all things considered
that was pretty entertaining uh i need
to i need to fill in the blank i didn't
get the end of that story
with him in durant but i mean i thought
what i know about it was pretty funny
yeah i don't know a lot of people say
that it was
or i've heard a couple people say that
it could have been him trying to
distract everybody from the fact that he
sued barstool sports for defamation to
character
because that looked like the ultimate
[ __ ] move
because okay so he worked for barstool
for a while
um as a sports commentator
and bar stool
fired him and then they and then he
talks some [ __ ] about
uh dave portnoy the guy who runs
barstool the president of barstool
and then dave portnoy who's like the
face of barstow sports released a
t-shirt
with rappaport's face depicted as a
clown
with like a herpe on his chin and
rappaport
sued barstool for defamation of
character
so now you have the king of [ __ ] talk
who roasts everybody on social media
says the worst most foul [ __ ] about
you and your mother on social media
whoever it might be that dude has no
boundaries
suing somebody from definition character
for a clown t-shirt
that didn't look good so and then
literally like the next day is when the
kevin durant beef drop
you know came out so i thought that was
pretty interesting
you did you didn't hear anything about
the bar stool stuff no i now that you
mentioned i think i might have i just
didn't like do it do a deep dive i mean
listen again sports entertainment blog
like even even the lawsuit sounds like
fun you know you know what i mean like
it's it's it's like i don't know the
whole thing just just plays
like um just plays like
television or drama or comedy or tragedy
depending on i guess how you're how you
look at it
um you know what was the was that um
[Music]
mel brooks's uh definition of what's the
difference between tragedy and comedy
um tragedy is when i trip and fall and
break my face
comedy is when you trip and fall and
break your face you know
so i don't know like but again
everything you just described to me
sounds like the wwe
you're totally right about that yeah
what we were talking about with the hulk
and randy beef where kind of like
it all spills outside the ring and the
line starts to blur
between the kind of persona and
entertainment versus real life or you
know like
how does this how to sort of like tweef
to
you know twitter beef how does tweef
kind of like spill out
into litigation like i mean i don't know
listen it's the reason why you and i
still have jobs it's the reason why
there's
there's podcasts you know there's a lot
of [ __ ] to talk about there's a lot of
[ __ ] to make
to make documentaries about you know